no one talks to me like that obviously
someone should it's been ten years since
Victoria Justice first starred in the
popular Nickelodeon series victorious
and long gone are the days when she was
booking successful TV shows like The
Suite Life of Zack & Cody iCarly and
Zoey 101
unfortunately her career has quickly
fizzled join us as we take a deeper look
at Victoria Justice the dark side of her
Nickelodeon experience and its aftermath
that negatively impacted the direction
of her entire career Victoria Justice
grew up in Hollywood Florida and at the
age of 10 after landing a walk-on role
on the hit show Gilmore Girls the
aspiring actress and her parents made
the big move to the other Hollywood in
California in 2005 less than two years
after Victoria was accepted into the
musical theatre program at the Milliken
Performing Arts Academy in Los Angeles
during that time she even appeared in
advertisements for Ralph Lauren guests
gap and yes even peanut butter toast
crunch cereal that same year she was
booking acting jobs on such shows as The
Suite Life of Zack and Cody as well as a
reoccurring role on the Nickelodeon TV
show zoey 101
soon after the show's creator dan
schneider was so impressed with the
talented young star that he created a
leading role for her in her very own
show the one we all know and love
victorious you could say the Victoria
was quickly making her way up the acting
ladder and was making a substantial mark
in the entertainment world things were
moving quickly and Victoria's career was
taking off you know you're actually not
terrible things were going extremely
well for Victoria and her acting career
she even began building her singing
career due to the huge success of her
hit TV show however after three seasons
of victorious everything came to an
unexpected end the show was abruptly
canceled in 2013 and it didn't even get
a proper finale episode there was so
much mystery around it ending and
there's much speculation as to why one
of the biggest accusations was that
Victoria wanted to leave the show to
focus on her singing career and was in
fact going off to do a solo tour after
the last season
others blamed Victoria's co-star ariana
grande because she was about to star in
her own spin-off series salmon cat a lot
of tension surrounded the accusations
and fans were angry with Ariana but she
quickly crushed the rumors that it
wasn't her fault she instead blamed
Victoria in a response in her ask.fm
account saying the only reason
victorious ended is because one girl
didn't want to do it
Toria responded on Twitter saying some
people would throw someone that they
consider a friend under the bus just to
make themselves look good
hashtag stop being a phony hashtag if
they only knew
yikes so much drama another unfortunate
realization of the show was that
although it was very popular and its
viewership was reaching two million
viewers on average the show failed to
create hit songs
unlike other popular shows such as Glee
who had a whopping 207 hit songs
throughout at six seasons the show's
victorious album hit number five on the
top 200 billboard list but only sold
40,000 copies it's quite possible that
because the show didn't feature charting
music that Nickelodeon didn't see it
making enough substantial profits from
the show so they decided to cancel it as
successful as the show was turns out
parents hated it many complains that the
parents in the show were portrayed as
pushovers and that the show represented
a false reality of the average teenage
girl they also complained that the show
lacked diversity another odd fact about
victorious was that it had a very strict
rule surrounding the actresses
hairstyles the show's creator Dan
Schneider implemented the rule that all
girls on the show must swear their hair
down he even revealed in his Dan Warp
blog as everyone who works for me knows
I almost never let girls wear ponytails
on my shows only once do we see Victoria
in a ponytail during the scene where she
has to pick up a huge mess Snyder said
it was necessary for that scene because
of the large mess the character would
have to clean up and that's why her hair
is in a ponytail
one of the biggest and darkest
controversies to come out of Victoria's
experience on the show was her feud with
ariana grande and the show was cancelled
there was quite a lot of finger-pointing
in regards to who was to blame for its
ending and to further the tension and
add fuel to the feud an interview
article in Seventeen magazine with
ariana grande had quoted her saying I
worked with someone who told me they'd
never like me but for some reason I just
felt like I needed her approval
so I started changing myself to please
her it made me stop being social and
friendly I was so unhappy many suspected
that Ari was referring to her victorious
co-star however Victoria two years later
on the Meredith Vieira show had
explained you know how the media like
twist words I was not talking about you
obviously like I was talking about one
of someone on Broadway
sadly once the thought was put out there
it's hard to make it go away no matter
how many photo ops and even reunions you
do fans have been speculating for years
since the show ended that there was
definitely a feud between them in April
2015
Victoria when asked if she would ever
work with Ariana again was quoted as
saying I think we're kind of both on our
separate paths right now I've been more
focused on acting and she's doing her
singing thing and doing awesome
many contemplated that it was blessed to
do with different career paths and more
to do with their dislike for each other
it didn't help that several years after
that in 2018 ariana released a video for
her song thank you next and although it
features several members from the cast
of Victorious such as daniella monet
Matt Bennett and Liz Gillies justice was
nowhere to be seen further fueling the
feud theories about the two girls after
having to leave Coachella early in 2019
fans assume Victoria was avoiding ariana
by leaving the event right before
Grande's performance Victoria quickly
responded with the video clearing up any
confusion that she bailed because she
didn't want to see her friends perform
and although at the time it went
unnoticed the feud between Victoria and
Ariana caused an old video from 2010 to
resurface Victoria was accused of being
jealous of Ariana receiving compliments
over her beautiful voice and how she is
always singing on set when all the girls
in the video were talking about
they love to sing Victoria added that
brings us to April 2020 doing a zoom
video call for the show's cast ten year
reunion a viewer commented I think we
are all the best in reference to that
same video from 10 years prior
Ariana's shot down the commenter
immediately squashing any resurfacing of
those old feud rumors so maybe there
isn't a feud but maybe there is we might
never know
unfortunately for Victoria it has only
continued the speculation and gossip
about anything she does that happens to
be connected to Arianna it's something
that she will never be able to escape
sadly even if her in Ariana's feud is
not true a fictional notion that justice
is mean and difficult to work with has
hurt her reputation and career that
brings us to Victoria's failing career
since her time on victorious victorious
is a beautiful talented actress and once
starred as the lead in her own TV show
so why did her career seem to tank after
victorious was cancelled it obviously
isn't due to lack of talent as justice
is a triple threat talented in acting
singing and dancing you would think she
would be unstoppable booking hit roll
after roll but her career has gone
nowhere
sadly Victoria just can't seem to make
anything stick since victorious after
leaving the show she set out on building
her music career and her first debut
song gold never made it to the top 100
billboard lists nor did it see much in
sales her album only sold a mere 30,000
copies Victoria left her label with
Columbia Records and decided to focus on
her acting career her first big movie
after victorious called fun-sized tanked
from there she was only able to acquire
small roles in shows like man with the
plan
Queen America an American housewife
eventually Victoria was able to land a
leading role in the TV show I candy but
it was cancelled after one season she
also starred as Janet in the TV movie
Rocky Horror Picture Show back in 2016
but the movie also flopped only getting
a 25% rating on Rotten Tomatoes
it seems lately her choice of film and
television shows are much darker and
more adults than we are used to seeing
her in like eye candy or 50 states of
fright there are much different types of
characters than her original role as
Tori Vega in victorious perhaps her
fanbase has trouble seeing her in any
other way and she unfortunately is
suffering from the typecasting curse
unfortunately it makes me so sad there
is speculation that her failing career
is due to the fact that she lacks brand
and her persona is somewhat boring she
has sort of a plain Jane vibe about her
and in an industry where image is
everything and you need to constantly
stand out amongst the crowd her sweet
teeny bopper persona no longer serves
her in her career she is often mistaken
for Nina Dobrev not to mention compared
to several other celebrities which in
some ways is seen as a huge compliment
of the actress but it also is a
deterrent in the casting room casting
directors are always looking for someone
who stands out from the rest
unfortunately it's easy for them to
choose another actress over her what's
the worst thing you've ever done I
squirted hot cheese over my friend and
her current boyfriend
with all these unlucky career flops we
wonder how Victoria was able to snatch
the hosting job for the upcoming Kids
Choice Awards with someone who is hardly
ever in the spotlight it does seem odd
to give her the hosting gig however
interestingly enough the original
broadcast of the first episode of
Victorious took place following the Kids
Choice Awards back in 2010 we wonder if
there is something in the works that
will be announced on the awards show
seeing as it is the 10-year reunion of
victorious perhaps a reboot or an
entirely new show featuring Victoria
Justice the fact that she was chosen to
host the award show tells us that she
hasn't completely lost her popularity
amongst teens otherwise she would never
have been picked in the first place her
job as host will definitely bring her to
the online forefront of viewers and fans
alike creating more and better
opportunities for her in the future the
awards show will be airing live via the
internet a first for any award show
since the corona virus pandemic the show
was originally set up to be hosted by
chance the rapper but now has Victoria
to take the reins for whatever reason
you may think Victoria's career has
flopped or at least fizzled we can't
help but think her negative experience
on Victorious was a huge cause of her
downfall
from feuds and constant gossip it's easy
to peg Victoria as difficult to work
with
we hope her hosting duties will help
boost her career in a better more
positive direction and she finally
starts to see the success she has been
working so hard to achieve what do you
think was Victoria's Nickelodeon
experience really that dark she
definitely had to endure some difficulty
surrounding the show but more so since
her days as a Nickelodeon star with a
career that seems to have flopped we'll
see what happens to her new hosting gig
in May 20-22 you think she'll do a good
job let us know in the comments below